i know it's early but i have got a shot
and a chaser for you here's the shot
you'd often get asked look the
republicans don't play it square why do
you play it square yeah well well guess
what if we do the same thing they do our
democracy will literally be in jeopardy
well yeah i'm not a joke
and i i understand that argument but
also it's like you're playing monopoly
with somebody who you know won't pass go
and won't follow any of the rules and
how do you ever make any progress if
they're not
following the rules
uh you know
and there's that little box directly to
jail
directly
that's the president of the united
states saying on national television
that the only way to deal with
republicans is to throw them in jail
that's the shot here's the chaser
yesterday the fbi arrested a republican
candidate for governor in michigan over
misdemeanors that he allegedly committed
on
january 6th of last year
a serious rival to the incumbent
governor was arrested during an election
year over relatively minor crimes that
he may or may not have committed more
than a year ago
for some reason the fbi did not see fit
to arrest this guy for well over a year
after the alleged incident took place
but then the very week that democrats
are staging their january 6th show trial
in circus
the fbi decides to arrest a prominent
republican office seeker for
misdemeanors related to the topic of the
hearings what are the odds boy oh boy
what a coincidence with each passing day
our country seems more and more to
resemble a banana republic
and for some strange reason it's
precisely the people who constantly
preen about our sacred democracy who
seem to be leading us faster and faster
toward it come on jack come on man well
i play by the rules man that's what i do
i don't that listen if i didn't play by
the rules unlike those pesky republicans
our democracy would fall apart that's
that's the first thing joe biden says in
the first half of his breath and then
what in the second half he says and
that's why i've got to jail my opponents
for opposing me
he used to be a little bit better with
the messaging joe biden he used to be a
little bit better with the bs and that
has gone out the window the appearance
on jimmy kimmel was absolutely
disastrous the the clip of it that's
going around right now that probably
went most viral was joe biden rambling
about
biracial television commercials
i'm serious you turn on the tv look at
the ads when's the last time you saw
biracial couples on tv when's the last
time you saw the way i mean people are
selling products they do ads to sell
products and they sell products when
people they appeal to people this
generation is going to change everything
we just got to make sure we don't give
up
when was the last time that you saw a
biracial there are so many things wrong
with this joe biden has used this line a
lot but he got it backwards this time
the the line that he usually uses to
show the progress that america has made
is that now you can't turn on a tv
without seeing an interracial couple
which is true there are a lot of
it is it is sort of odd actually that
interracial couples seem to be far more
represented on television than in the
united states at large but but that's
what he's pointing to except he got it
backwards and he can't keep his words
right anymore and he blames it on a
childhood stutter that he had when he
was eight that disappeared for 70 years
and then popped back up again so he got
it wrong and he said you don't see
biracial couples also he doesn't know
what the word biracial means biracial is
like halle berry
if we were talking about biracial
couples on tv we would say that everyone
on tv were halle berry hewed and they
were all they were
slightly only slightly darker than i am
the word that he's looking for is
interracial so
the only reason i bring it up is not to
make any point about his stupid
observation on the tv it's to point out
even the lines that he is most practiced
with even the lines that he has used in
his stump speeches for years now even
those get jumbled up in his mushy
pudding head then
joe biden rambles so badly
that that jimmy kimmel actually has to
cut him off and go to commercial
but here's the deal
one of the things is that it's very
difficult now
to have a
even
with notable exceptions even the really
good reporters they have to get number
clicks on on on nightly news
so instead of asking a question
anyway it just everything gets
gets sensationalized and weighs it but
i'm convinced we can get through this we
have to get through it and one of the
things look i'm going to take a break
and then we'll talk a little bit more if
you don't mind i'm sorry i'm sorry we
have some of those commercials we have
some biracial commercials we need to
show we'll be back with president
that was a pretty good save by jimmy
kimmel but it was so sad how he had to
lean into it because he leaned into it
the way that when when you've really got
to go to a meeting when you've really
got to get off the phone and you're
speaking with an elderly relative the
way you hey hey before hold on before
you get into that story
great great grandpa we need i just we're
gonna take a little break okay and then
and then he makes the biracial joke
which was which was pretty funny but
it's not funny enough to save the
interview what does biden talk about you
know back in my day sonny we didn't have
all these clicky clicky doodads and
websites we had the pony express and
that's what that's what we did jack and
we would go and you'd have to you go to
the gutenberg press to if you wanted
your news stories
but then okay hey hold on
just one second there mr president we've
got to go cut to commercial to end this
misery
and then finally the the probably the
most important point worth mentioning in
this disastrous interview
was that joe biden is appearing on jimmy
kimmel
the night after
a leftist assassin showed up to brett
kavanaugh's house because he was upset
about the court potentially overruling
roe versus wade which he only found out
about because a leftist on the court
leaked it and he found brett kavanaugh's
address only because a leftist group
doxed kavanaugh and the night after that
happens
joe biden shows up to this national talk
show very few people watch it but still
a national show
and he says if the court overrules row
by golly you might get a revolution
it's clear that if in fact the decision
comes down the way it does and these
states impose the limitations they're
talking about it's going to cause a mini
revolution they're going to vote a lot
of these folks out of office a mini
revolution now biden is a shrewd enough
politician still that he know he he
teases that
but then he pulls it back he says
they're by voting it's going to be a
revolution by voting
but but joe biden does know the context
here and the context actually does
matter here he's showing up hours after
a leftist assassin tries to murder a
sitting supreme court justice over this
issue specifically in his home in his
bed where the justice's wife and
daughters sleep
and then biden
instead of instead of going on the
kimmel show and condemning that
i don't think biden knows about very
much these days but they certainly told
him that someone tried to kill the
justice
instead of going on and saying listen we
need to cool down the rhetoric we need
to restore the soul of a nation we need
to not be killing federal officials
certainly not judges at least no instead
of that he says hey
hey you know that thing that the cabin
almost got murdered for yeah well
i sure hope kavanaugh changes his mind
you know because hey listen jack listen
corn pop if he doesn't we might get a
mini revolution you know what i'm saying
hey come on there come on man come on
man come on i'm so glad you like that
clip now if you wouldn't mind ring smash
like click bang wang what about a bing
bang go to the michael knowles show get
those notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you